[Music]
pop quiz who is this
[Music]
if you answered Olympic gold-medalist
freestyle skier Jonny Moseley you are
correct it is Tonya Moseley hey I'm
Jonny Moseley here's another question
what exactly is Jonny Moseley doing
right now
it's strange it's as if Jonny is figure
skating on skis what you're witnessing
is a rare glimpse of a lost athletic art
that was once the pinnacle of freestyle
skiing it had judges it had costumes it
had fans it had a name ski ballet in the
beginning dunphy saw skiers didn't just
want to ski down they wanted to ski fun
and they invented a new sport that would
eventually make it all the way to the
Olympic Games ski ballet was born
yeah it just looked like a bunch of
crazy stuff on skis this is three-time
world champion skier Bob Howard a legend
in ski ballet when the sport was in this
1980s heyday what they didn't know then
you don't know now ski ballet is very
difficult I'd like to demonstrate from
an easier shot so I brought in Jonny
Moseley I'm Jonny Moseley they know ski
ballet was a form of freestyle skiing
and it had a couple different
corporations it had both flips
[Music]
spins linking tricks we put it all
together with rock-and-roll music early
on we did some moves that we're
basically flexed tricks where you go off
your tips and what it is is you flex
your tip up and you spin around those
are pretty difficult because you're
balancing and you can hurt yourself real
quickly you can dislocate your knee and
an instant here's Johnny doing a 720
which is two times around we copied this
from ice-skating and then even goes to a
higher level where he goes to a 900
which means he spins around two times
lands backwards the lights and ski
ballet were never brighter than when
there was a demonstration sport in the
Olympics in 1988 and 1992 but ski ballet
was not long for this world
the spotlight dimmed when the games
dropped it in 1994 and the whole sport
went fully dark not long after the DNA
of ski ballet is actually in everything
that freestyle is today all the spins
and moves you see in the slopestyle in
the big era we did all that in the very
beginning that's why I teach my students
key ballet moves
start that exact quote
so the next time you're on a chairlift
and you spied Jonny Moseley down below
clad in a retro onesie and painting a
ski masterpiece on a canvas of virgin
snow take a moment to realize that your
glimpsing the flight of a Phoenix a
Phoenix called ski ballet
you
when were younger I never thought I
looked any different than her we didn't
understand why people would be like are
you actually sisters were like yeah
obviously my name is Hannah Brandt I
played for Team USA my name is Marissa
Brandt and I play for Team South Korea
sisters I was born in Seoul South Korea
and I was adopted when I was four months
old I want to play into the States and
that's where I met my parents I started
playing hockey when I was eight and you
started I started when I was about five
years old we did everything together
growing up so really I chose hockey just
to be able to be with her but as I got
older I really learned to love this
sport we played together through high
school and then we went our separate
ways for college
and we're on opposite ends of the world
every day we talk and text and asked
about how each other's days went in
games and whatnot so yeah I mean being
so far away we stay connected somehow I
think it's a super cool thing that we're
both going to the Olympics playing for
different teams and in the same sport I
don't know how common that is so I think
it makes it that much more special for
us but I think for our family and
friends that they have two teams to root
for it just so happy to be able to
continue to play the sport I love it be
able to go to the Olympics with this one
[Music]
[Applause]
hockey has shaped and influenced both of
our lives growing up so I can't imagine
a better reason to be able to go back to
my home country it through hockey for me
going to the Olympics is kind of always
been a dream of mine and then to be able
to watch my sister do the same thing and
to be able to go through this experience
with her is just a dream come true
[Music]
at the top of the track right before a
race
I tell myself there's nothing I can't do
people have died doing this and I know
that but going 90 miles per hour is so
damn fun my name is John Daly and I'm a
two-time Olympic skeleton slider a
skeleton track is roughly one mile long
and I'll slide up to 90 miles per hour
with my face only one inch off the ice
you get a green light and you take off
sprinting and you can't hear a thing
when I make contact with the sled it
feels like a place I've been my whole
life
last 15 years I've made that same jump
onto the sled
you could feel immense pressure as
you're pulling 5 G's so my eight pound
head now weighs 40 pounds
if you start to get stiff you start to
get scared it's not gonna work the sleds
gonna break loose on you and you are
gonna crash you have to embrace the
speed instead of getting afraid of it at
the bottom of the skeleton race when
I've had a really good run I feel like I
could run through the wall
you're so pumped up and that's why I
love it
[Music]
you
[Music]
when I go down the slope it takes me
three seconds to get from zero to sixty
miles an hour I honestly can't explain
what it feels like even after 15 years
of doing this floor my name is Sarah
Hendrickson and I'm an Olympic ski
jumper ski jumping is a sport where I go
down a two track slope at 55 miles an
hour and when the slope ends I jump
flying about a football field in length
in the air when I'm getting ready to go
the smell is of the fresh air from the
trees and the snow in the area and the
feeling of cold brisk air on my face
when I put my goggles on I know it's
time to go
[Music]
my eyesight when I'm going down the
slope is right in front of the tips of
my skis my skis are bouncing up and down
in the track against the ice it feels
like clatter if you hear it it's like a
lung Bowl the flight takes three seconds
but honestly time slows down and it
feels like an eternity where I get to
enjoy flying as I'm flying I can't hear
anything it's completely silent all
around the wind on my body feels like
when you put your hand out of a car
window going 60 miles an hour moving it
up and down you can feel the lift and
drag it has on your hand
that's like ski jumping but for your
whole body as I'm flying I'm totally
alone I'm in control of all my senses
and all my movements it's the best
feeling in the world
you
[Music]
bobsledding is a Winter Olympic sport
where you have your driver and you have
a brakeman which is my position the
brakeman is mainly the engine to the
sled we get it going as fast as possible
I am aja Evans and I'm an Olympic
bobsledder the track is about a mile
long and full of twists and turns and
can get up to 90 miles an hour the
moment I zip up my speed suit I feel
like a complete superhero it's almost
like I hear the theme music in my head
I'm ready to go
as we're going to the track picking up
speed we start to pull about 5 G's which
is five times the force of gravity so
it's literally what a fighter pilot
experiences
it's like someone's jumping on you
things out of nowhere you just feel all
this pressure on your lower back it's a
pretty noisy ride my head is rattling
throughout the sled I'm trying to stay
low
as soon as it's over I can inhale start
breathing again
[Music]
you
[Music]